some of these clowns in these left
states don't appreciate you
Unfortunately they don't find a place
that they value the first time I moved
to Cal to Texas I couldn't believe the
level of unreasonable hospitality and
Southern Hospitality I was getting yes
sir can I get you this yes sir yes sir
I'm like California sir sir sir sir sir
would you like this would you like that
yes sir there is pride in people that
create businesses whoever the Walgreens
Founders is that created that business
salute to you and whoever that chose to
close that place down because they don't
respect your business good for you as
well to the community that's pissed off
about walgree shutting down call her ass
out y call her out don't blame Walgreens
out call her out cuz Walgreens has no
problem being in your community and and
taking care of all the clients there
they genuinely want to do that but if
they're losing money and they're being
robbed and their employees are being
held at gun help yeah they have to shut
down and protect the customers and their
employees what a pathetic argument